サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッソウパサンパダ サチットパリヨダパナン エタングブッダナササナング
まあこちらに狙撃でライト当たってますから
皆様の顔は見えません
真っ暗闇でね お化けのような方々に説法するっていう
[笑い]そういう訓練したことがないんですね
ちょっと俺の方に光をちょっと入れた方がいいと思いますけどね
すいません あの 申し訳ないですけど
室内客席を少し明かりを入れていただくことできますでしょうか
もう少しですかね もう少し明るくください
顔を見える見えるように
まあその方がスライドは見やすいんですが
まあ皆様のことを全く心配できませんからね
こういう真っ暗だったらもう寝ちゃうでしょ
寝てもいいんだから いびきかいちゃうとどうしようかなと
じゃああの 今日のテーマで喋ることにします
えーとですね あの このようなテーマの場合は
本当はスライドない方がいいと思いますけど
説法形式で喋った方がよく理解できるところがいっぱいあるんですね
だから私としてはかなり年取っちゃったんだから
毎日計算するんですよ
あとあと何日ですか 何年ですかとかね
ですから この知識を肥やす話したってもう意味がないでしょうと
早く早く人生を成長する話をしなくちゃいけないのではないかというね
考えもあります これ ブッダのご機嫌でしたっけ？ご機嫌教室
それ発表しているタイトルで
微笑みが連鎖する生き方
はい あの まあ仏教はね
昔 お釈迦様の時代から人々に馬鹿にされるわ
批判されるわね 世の中の人々は自分たちがすごく頭がいいと思っているんですね
で 自分のスリランカのお寺にいる野良犬たちいてね
あの連中を私よりすごく頭がいいと思っているんです
超迷惑ですけどね で 勝手に部屋に入ったり
まあ私を私をリードしてどこかに連れて行こうかと思ったりとかね
まあそういう感じでね
お釈迦様は完全なる悟りを開いて
世の中でね 誰にも攻撃できない
批判できない 反論できない
確固たる事実を語られたところで
これを馬鹿にしようとするんですね
お釈迦様もそれによって何も
言ってはないんだけど
まあ言ったのはできることなら挑戦してみてください
自我がないとある日お釈迦様がおっしゃったんですね
実体がないんだ すべて無常で変化する流れです
だからまあ 当たり前のこと
川の実体ないし 川っていうのは水が流れる
だから瞬間瞬間水は別々なものなんですね
同じ水ではありません
ずっと上の方から水だけで流れて流れて
まあ海に行っちゃうんですね
だから瞬間たりともこれが川というものはない
俗世間的に まあ一般論として川があると言える
しかし 科学的に客観的にどちらが川ですかというと
それはないんですね だから言葉は 2つの立場で使ってくださいと
世間一般論で言葉を使う
それから真理を示すための言葉を使うというね
あの 2つの立場で仏教は言葉を使っているんです
それを今日言いたかったのは
この  アナータピンディカ・コジというお釈迦様に大変お世話した財家の信者さんがいてね
豊かな人で お釈迦様に最初に住むところ
僧房をね 作ってあげた人で
お釈迦様は木の下でずっと生活していたんですね
だから この人は悟った人が現れているのだと聞いてびっくりしちゃって
で 会いに行こうかなと思ったんです
だから 自分の国じゃない別な隣の国に行った時の友達の同じ金持ちの家に泊まっていたんです
その人がかなり忙しくて
普通は自分の接待することに忙しくなるのに
自分のことを置いておいて忙しい
なんでそんな忙しいのか
王様でも来るのかと聞いたら
いえ もっと偉い人が明日来るんだよと
悟った人がいるんだよ
私は明日お布施を用意しているんだから
との言葉を聞いただけで
アナータピンディカ・コジがね
びっくりしちゃって ぜひ会いたい
ぜひ会いたいと言って
まあだから夜は大体もう三時
四時ぐらいでこの人は出て行っちゃった
あまりにブッダのことで喜びを感じたんだから
その時は光が現れるんですね
それは皆様にはないんだけど
この道場なんかでヴィパッサナーの瞑想でもやっていると
ある段階があって もう何でも見える
光って見えるようになっちゃうんですね
自分にとっては世は暗く
暗くないんで 道場はもう夜は真っ暗なんで
もう全部電気消して みんな歩く瞑想したり
座り瞑想したりする まあそれは仏教ではね
障害 解脱に障害というんですけど
この光が現れることは
それはもうすごい直ちにこれはもう足すんです
で あまり良くないんです
しかし 光が現れたら もう真夜中であっても
それもものは見える 一般人が欲がある人々は
これはえらいこっちゃと思っちゃうんですね
それは執着するんです
仏教はこれはとても危険なことであると
直ちに執着を捨てなさいと
無常は無常と観察してね
その光が消えてしまうところまで頑張っちゃうんです
で はい だからこのアナータピンディカ・コジにも
やっぱりブッダのことを念じてると
すごく光が現れて 本人にわからない
本人にとってはもう まあ日が昇ったでしょう
という感じなんです 日が昇って全部見えるんだと言って
森の中に入ったんです
一人一人危険で 普通は結構警備と一緒に行くのに
行って歩いて歩いて疲れてくると
ちょっと集中力が壊れちゃって
光が消えちゃって真っ暗
それで あ 怖くなったんだけど
でも怖くなったってしょうがない
ブッダに会わなくちゃと思って
また気持ちが止まる とまた光が出て
そういうことで とにかく長い距離を歩いてお釈迦様のところに行ったら
これ冬で でお釈迦様は森の中で薄い落ち葉をね
ほんのちょっとギザギザのところで
落ち葉をちょっと拭いて
そこら辺で座ってるんですね
寝ていたわけじゃないんですね
だから 極度に贅沢に生活する人にとっては
はい 一番の悟った人がね
誰よりも優れた境地に達したこの聖者がいるところは何だと
この木の下で もうまた真冬
あの 石ガレドロドロドロ石があるところでね
なんとか枯れ葉を拭いて
ちょっと柔らなもので座っていることでね
残念でしょうがなかった
その時 有名な言葉でお釈迦様はいかがでしょうか？夜よく寝られたでしょうか？と聞くんですね
でお釈迦様の答えは 世の中でよく寝られると言ったら
まああれは私のことだと
言って これで説法して
まあ彼は仏教徒になって
それから仏教を応援するためにものすごい活動をなさっている
で この遺跡は今でもありますよ
祇園精舎とマヘー マヘップサヘっていう
今その名前でインドにね
まあかなりのお寺 カスカスですよ
何千人も坊さんたち住んでいたところですからね
だからこの冬 外で木の下で過ごす羽目になったと言ったら
私たちから見ればもう世界一不幸なやつなんですね
ホームレス程度ではない
もっとひどいではないかと思っちゃうんですね
しかし お釈迦様が言うのは
世界で私ほど安穏で安全で楽しく寝られる人はいませんと
で それからこのインドの宗教者たちがみんなこの苦行をやるんですね
修行と言って 人間というのはすごい面白い生き物なんですよ
で 例えば仏教の場合でも
仏教はブッダが悟って語ったもので
仏教を実践するべきかということが
お釈迦様が指導しなくちゃあかんですよ
それって常識でしょ 何か新しい科学的な何か発明ではなくて
発見したら それを発見した学者が発表しなくちゃいけないんですね
それで悟った方はどうすれば悟るのかと教えなくちゃいけないんです
しかし 世の中は ブッダに修行を教えるんですね
宗教家に あなた方はこういうふうに修行しなさいと
俗世間で怒り 嫉妬 憎しみに溺れている世間がアドバイスするんです
それだけアホじゃないんです
自分たちがアドバイスしていることにすら気づいてないんです
それだけじゃないんです
この修行というくだらんことをやっている連中が
聖なる聖者たちの教えを学んでいるんじゃなくて
くだらない酒飲んで酔っ払って喧嘩して人殺したり
動物殺ったりしている
この社会のどん底で生きている人々の指導で生きているということに気づいてないんです
だから人間と付き合うことほど世の中で気持ち悪いことはないんですよ
それも仏教の まあ一応言ってはいるんです
まあ慈しみあるんだから
人間から逃げることはしませんだけどね
で どういうことかというと
この欲に溺れてもっと贅沢したい
もっと美味しいものを食いたい
もっと酒飲みたいとか
そうやってこの肉体存在で苦しんでいる連中が
修行なら自分たちでやってやっていることの反対ではないかと勝手に思って
宗教者に苦行をやりなさいと
俺たちが食ってるんだから
お前らは食うなよ 俺たちは酒飲んでるのに
お前は酒飲むなよ 俺たちは結婚して子育てしてるのは
あなた方は結婚しないで子育てしてはいけませんとかね
俺たちは普通の服着てるけれど
お前らは裸でいなさいとかね
我々は家で住んでいるのは
あなた方は外で森の中で住みなさいと
こいつら悟ってるんですかね
この哀愁の連中が それでせっかく出家したいと思う
自分たちがどんな修行すればいいか
自分たちの先輩とかね
そういう他の同業者から学ばなくちゃあかんでしょうね
これは歴史上起きてないんですね
この社会現象っていうのは
一神教を語っているこの原始人がいる
このヨーロッパの方も西洋の方も同じなんですね
あの連中 原始人だから別に構いませんだけど
例えばカトリック教の神父さんは結婚しない
それどういうわけかよくわからない
しかし キリスト教っていうのは
人々の日常のお祭りを盗んだんですね
キリスト教あろうがなかろうが
人類が現れるから 文明がなんとなくじわじわと発展してくると
人間というのは結婚システムを作ったんです
一人で結婚するか二人で結婚するか
それは関係なかったんだけど
一応男と女が一緒に生活して子育てをする
それは家族ということで
そこでそれなりに約束事をね
じゃあお前と私が一緒に生活しますという約束なんですね
結婚というのは それは誰かの先輩のおじいさんかおばあさんか
誰かそこら辺の年の長老
誰かの許可を得て結婚式ですね
そういう結婚式 キリスト教などなどを奪っちゃったんですね
俺たちがやるのはうちじゃないんだ
で 葬式も同じで それはこちらで教会の仕事だと
それを奪って教会で結婚式をやっているんです
しかし 結婚式をやっている神父が結婚しないんですね
こんな悪いことだったら
お前なんで人にそんなひどい目に人をひどい目に遭わせるのかと聞きたくない
結婚って素晴らしいことだって
あなた先に結婚しなさいと言わなくちゃいけないでしょ
で そこは変やということで
このイングリッシュチャーチというね
イギリス教会なんだらかんだらプロテスタント
プロテスタント教会とかいくつかありますね
まあ結婚するというね
結婚して一般人にやることは何でもやると
だからこのイングリッシュチャーチの場合は
もう一般人よりは最低の人間が教会関係ある人々なんです
歴史いろいろ歴史を読んでみてください
はい  そこでどういうことかというと
私は神父だ 神のために命を捧げている人だ
どんな生き方をすればよろしいのかと
それだったら神のしもべとして
これはわからない それでまたあいつの連中から話に行くんです
それはもう我々は結婚して
普通の仕事をしてね やっているんだから
あんた方はそれやるなよ
それだけの話です いかに世界がアホかと
宗教世界もどれほどアホの塊かということなんです
この欠点を教えるのが仏教の仕事なんです
何をやっているのかと
誰も褒め称えるために来たわけ現れたわけじゃないんです
アホがアホであることに気づかないんだから
アホにアホであると気づかせてあげるんです
お釈迦様は言葉でそれを教えているんですよ
アホが自分で賢者と思ったら
永久的にアホで終わっちゃって不幸になる
んだろうと 自分がアホバカだとわかった人は成長するんだよと
ダンマパダにあるんですね
その偈は はい そういうことで
インドのブッダの時代でみんなハチャメチャ苦行をする
でお釈迦様も菩薩の時
仕方がなく ...お釈迦様の立場が弱いんですね
王子だから 極国の贅沢する生活から出家したんだから
だから他の宗教家みたいにやることはなくて
財産もなくて 奥さんに逃げられて出家したわけじゃないんです
あるいは犯罪を起こしちゃって
王に捕まされないようにとか
いろんな理由で出家する
ブッダはそうじゃないんですね
だからインドの宗教家たちにとっては
苦しい生活っていうのはもう慣れたもんですね
シッダルタ王子はそれ慣れてないんです
でも出家したんだから
みんなの猿真似をしてみたんですね
しかし 人格者だから猿真似じゃなくて本格的にやってみたんです
苦行 やってみて こんなあまりにもアホらしいやと
これでは何の成長もないんだと
と思って捨てたんです
そこで言いたかったのは
宗教世界はみんなもう苦行しているんだから
見た目は悪い 服装なんかね
ものすごい汚い 汚れているし
お風呂に入らないわ 体洗わないわ
もう裸でいるわ いろいろ
一部の宗教家が髪の毛で布を織って
それ着るんですよ だから在家の人々の女たちが喜んで髪の毛切って差し上げるんです
それで布を織って これは腰巻きで巻いているんです
お釈迦様はある経典でね
世の中で人が着るものの中で最低な着るものが毛で作った
人間の毛 人間の髪の毛で作ったものだと １
感触がすごく悪い 皮膚が炎症を起こしちゃうんです
ものすごい苦しさを残すんです
それからものすごい 何て言いますか
悪臭？それからいろいろ寄生虫なんかは住みたい放題
普通の動物の毛はそういうものじゃないんです
変でしょう 変じゃないんです
人間の髪の毛はいらないものなんです
人間進化したところ 進化したならば
髪の毛はいらないんです
だから進化遅れて残っているアペンデンという
まあいらんもの だからそちらの自然的な整理整頓も起きません
動物の毛は必要です だから動物はお風呂に入らなくても何のことなく大丈夫です
毛が綺麗です だって一度たりともお風呂に入らない猫がどうでもいるんだからね
毎日はお風呂に入って来いと言ったら言って聞いてくれない
でも私よりは綺麗です
だからそれはもう進化過程では必要なもの
だから人間の毛はまあ
捨てた方がいいものなんです
でもあるんだから だから人間がそれにものすごい金かかって手をかかっているんです
いらんものを背負っているんだから
昨日店見たんだけど あのシャンプーの種類
そう まあちょっと読んで理解しようかなと思ったら
こうもう1日かかるんですよ
だからもうまあ結構あるものやということで省略したんです
そこで薬局に行ったら
もう日本の作ったシャンプーガラガラガラとあって
外国ブランドのものダラダラダラとあって
それから外国から輸入したシャンプーの種類があったりして
なんでそこまで髪の毛に苦労してるんですかね
それは体に入れないものなんですよ
だから放っておいちゃうとどうなるかわからない
これでもっと面白い話があります
私は怠けてやって 今 4 日間髪の毛剃らなかったんです 4
日  5 日間ぐらいね 昨日まで
そこで毛が出るでしょ
まあ細ね まあほんのちょっとですから
長く伸びたわけじゃないんだけど
それで朝お勤めする場合は
私 私はこの経典あげたりして
経典の項目ごとに礼をするんですね
で 礼をするときはこうやってするでしょ
こちらの毛がこちらに指に触れちゃうんです
これが痛くて痒くて炎症を起こしちゃって
今日もクリーム持って来たんです
昨日髪の毛剃ったんだけどね
自分の毛ですよ 私の体に毒になっている
アレルギー反応ではないんだけど
アレルギー反応のような
こうするとこうしちゃうんですね
こうしちゃうと髪の毛触れちゃうんですね
これってことになっちゃうんです
だから皆様方はすごい金かかるのは髪の毛にはね
まあわからないわけでもないんです
でも馬鹿は馬鹿ですよ
これ美しいやと勘違いしているんですね
そこら辺はもう完璧アホなんです
髪形どうしよう クレーンしますか？パーマかけるか
染めるか あれやこれやとかね
あのね これは放っておいたら臭くてあんた死ぬんだから
髪の毛洗ってください
それだけの話なんです
あんまり伸びちゃうとあなたに超迷惑だから切ってくださいと
それだったらもう馬鹿じゃないんです
ちゃんと進化過程で問題は知っている
それで進化するといろんないらんものあるでしょうに
あの男のおっぱいみたいに
あれ 何のためにあるかとさっぱりわからないでしょ
だって進化で男を雄雌分かれてならば
まあ雌は哺乳類の場合はおっぱいあげる
哺乳類雄は別に関係ないんだからおっぱいいらないんですね
でもあるんですね で 何のためにそれあるのかもわかりませんし
これでどうしましょうかと
何もないし   そんなもんで
それでこの宗教家たちが一部がね
けさカバラという髪の毛で作った衣を着ているブッダって
お釈迦様はこれだけはかなり悪口言ってます
世界で最低の着るものやと
で 木の皮着ている人々もいますけど
そんなんもうこれまあ奇数でしょうと
それで終わり 木の皮で腰巻き等使ってもそんなに炎症を起こしません
髪の毛だったら冗談でそれ使っちゃいけないんですね
人間の髪の毛はみんなカッシーラのために使うんですね
それはそんなに問題ないんですね
どうせ同じ仲間ですからね
じゃあ今日からなんか髪の毛で何かこうやって手袋とか何とか作ってはめてみてください
それから病院に行ってください
はい そういうことで この宗教たちっていうのは
もう非常に貧しくて見苦しくて
毎日苦行して 微笑みはない
苦境しているんです 今までのクンバメーラとか祭りやった時は
インドの行ってみることもできるし
ネットで見ることもできるし
どれほどこの聖者たちが汚くてかっこ悪くてダサいかと
聖者と名乗っているだけなんですけどね
はい それで仏教弟子たちが違うんです
ちゃんとお風呂に お風呂じゃなくて川に入って沐浴をする
衣はものすごく大事に洗って綺麗に着る
それで戒律では 例えば村に入って托鉢して道場に入る
戻るでしょ 道場で上半身裸では大丈夫です
衣切りすはないんです
腰巻きだけで十分です
そうするとこの衣って大きいんだから高価なものなんですね
衣をどこかで置いておかなくちゃいかん
その時も戒律はあるんですよ
衣はある程度で太陽に当ててくださいと
しかし 長い時間当てておいてはいけませんと
汗が衣についたら 決してそこで衣を保管してはいけないんです
汗が乾いたところで まず太陽に当たってみて
適当な時間だったらそれを取って折らなくちゃいけないんです
私の衣みたいに 私は全然折ります
取ったら折ったら幸運です
嫌だったら誰が来て整理整頓してやってもいいんだけど
私はやりません まあそれはいい
いいんじゃなくて それはそれで置いておいて
私は思うのは お釈迦様はどれほど細かく物事を教えるのか
だから衣をちゃんと折ってくださいと
折って竹竿があってね
そちらに入れてください
そちらに入れる前に手で竹竿を拭いてくださいと
手でチェックしてください
だからホコリだったら拭いてくださいなんです
それからそちらに入れてください
それで今日折ったら 明日衣を着て托鉢に行くでしょ
次の日は同じところで折ってはいけません
ちょっとずらして折ってください
それは品質の問題で インドの手作りのものだから
今はこういう化繊が入っているものだったら
どこを折ったってもね
まあ折りませんだからもう大丈夫ですけど
昔はね まあ手であれだから
同じところから折っちゃうと
麻などは切れる可能性あるんですね
そこまで丁寧できめ細かいです
仏教の戒律世界は だから億以上あるのは戒律項目
そういうわけなんです
はい そういうふうな生活をすると
俗世間よりみんなすごい品格のある
えらいかっこいい組織になるんです
言葉は丁寧で 挨拶はしっかりできてあって
歩く時 座る時 衣を着る時
喋る時 食べる時などなど
全部しっかりできてあって
これが本当にインド人にはもう見たことがないものなんです
なんてすごい組織ですかと
たとえ宮殿に行ったってもだらしないでしょうにと
軍人見たっても最低でしょうにと
それででした 仏弟子たちはな
褒めるべきところをこいつら非難するんです
世の中 で 仏教が全然アホに乗りませんだからね
ずっと依頼したんだけど
我々変えなかった 我々の生き方は
今もそうなんだ 皆様は何を思おうが
私は気にしない 喋ることは喋りますよ
日本の文化にちょっと合わないとか
日本の文化ってそんなに偉い？ブッダの悟りよりも
文化の価値っていうのは歴史の価値だけでしょう
文化を作るのはくだらない阿羅漢者たちでしょ
知識人文化作りませんよ
しきたり 習慣 お神輿を持っている時はふんどしでも行かなくちゃいけないとか
知識人はそれ決めませんでしょ
あるいは皇室の方々決めたんですかね
祭典ないでしょ？どこら辺のアホでしょ
それからそれを大事に守ってくる
だからって だから誰かの文化に合わないとかね
これ関係ない 智慧の完成者が言ったことは言う
傷ついたっても仕方がない
傷ついたったら 誰が？誰が悪い？仏教じゃなくてあんたが悪い
だからまあそういう態度で喋ってもポイントに入ります
そこでこの王様かな 誰かかなね
もうびっくりで 王様いくらか文化的な生活をする人だからね
なんでこの出家者見たらね
もう血管が出て 昔はよく病気があったんですね
この緑の野菜食べられなくなって
これを昔船旅する時にもかかったら
なんとか病気ありますね
はい はいはい 海結膜炎というなんとか病気にかかっていてね
で 眼涙虚線でね いろいろそれで仏教の人々はどんな苦しい状況に置かれてもよく微笑んでるんだと
明るいんだと 嫌な顔はないんだと
一体全体これって何なのかという質問があって
それに仏様が答えたんですが
まあ皆様がついています
私はその経典入れてないですけど
で 今日はだいたい一般論で行こうかなと思っています
はい 今日の私の狙いは
今から明るくなってください
明日遅いんです 皆さん明日からでしょ？だから修行してください
じゃあ明日からやります
早く出だしですね じゃあ明日からこのうちやります
と このうちと明日っていうのはもうそういう人やらないんですね
その明日からと言った時点でもう治らないぐらい末期状態の暗い人間なんです
明るい人間が今やるんです
だから仏教では明日からやるという話はどこにもないんです
これから頑張りなさいと
ないんです アッジーバキッチャンアタッパという
これは皆様にも暗記させるように
私はちょっとやってはいるんだけど
経典に入れてある 日常なんとか経典にアッジーキッチャンが当たったんだ
今日やりなさい 今日頑張りなさい
こうじゃにゃあならなし
あんた明日死んでるかも
だから今日やりなさいよと
そういうことだから だから初めからもう明るい世界を紹介しています
します 何でも今やるということにしてください
それで皆様明るくなるんです
じゃあ明日やりますではないんですよ
はい 今言ってるのは明るくいることだから
じゃあ今から明るくなってみてみてください
我々に明るくなれない理由があります
これはアプローチの問題なんです
すべて見方です 私個人がどんなような見方を持ってるのかと
その見方によって私の人生が築かれるんです
だから今日は仏教は今日だけの話ですからね
今日私の生き方は 今日の私の見方で成り立つんです
例えば 今私は元気で立ってガチャガチャ喋ってますけど
これ終わった家に戻った途端
どっかやん 疲れちゃったとかね
じゃあネットでも見ようかなとかなっちゃうんです
ここで元気で喋る私は
なんで自分の家に戻ったらだらしないおじいじに戻るんですかね
見方ですね 結局は 見方が変わった途端
もうすべて変わっているんです
それ 皆様経験してください
皆様の今 この講演ホールにいる時の見方と
講演が終わった途端 外へ出た時の見方が変わるでしょう
見方が変わった途端 人生も変わっているんです
電車に乗ったら見方が変わるでしょ
最初の挨拶で言いたかった言いたかったんですけどね
なんて言いますか あの雨も降ってね
ちょっと悪い天気の中で
大変申し訳ございませんが
あれやこれやとくだらん見方で
そこを言いたかったのは
なんて幸せでした 今日は雨も降っていたんだよと
あ よかった 雨が降ってくる
びしょ濡れで講演会に入りますよ
と思ったら明るいでしょう
あ 約束はしたんだけど
雨が降ってるんだから
まあ今日はちょっとやめますとかね
それ暗いでしょ でもそんな難しい明るく生きること？見方変えるだけでしょうに
だから今からできない？時間足さないんです
横浜講演に行った時でも雨でしたけど
まあまあタクシー来ていたんだから
私はさっと乗っちゃったんですね
そこで傘忘れちゃって
タクシーの中で あ 今日は雨で傘持ってなかった
持ってこなかったと出素人に言ったんですね
それだけで私はもう見方変えてますからね
講演終わって東京まで戻る
横浜までびしょ雨が降っても私には関係ないしね
雷が落ちちゃっても私には関係ないし
雷が私の頭の上に乗っちゃってもね
それも関係ないし あ よかったと
1 発射で死んじゃって
この一体どうやって火葬するのよ
困らなくて 皆さんみんな困らなくてよかったと
1 発射で火葬にもなっちゃってとかね
それで人々はこれでニュースに上がったり
雷で人が痛い知らない外人が死んじゃったとか言ってね
それに ああ どうですね
あのバカたちがどれほど苦しみますかとかね
だから楽しくてしょうがないね
私にとっては それで私は講演で言ったんですね
今日はどうせ傘持たなかったんだから
帰るところは必ず雨が降るんだよと
じゃなきゃ面白くないんだと
雨が降って傘を持ってるんだったら意味がないでしょ
雨が降ることに だって自分に何の関係もない
だから濡れた方がいいと
その冗談とアプローチはみんなあまり理解しないんです
だってみんな暗いんだからね
そこであのエレベーターのところで待っていると
ある若い女性の方がじーっと待っていて
傘を持って 先生 この傘を持っててくださいと
いいです 結構ですと思わなかったんですけどね
まあそこはそれで 別に心配していることはわかりますけど
逆に誰かがうるさいばあちゃんがね
今日あんた傘持ってこなかったんだから
もうビショビショ濡れて帰ってくださいと言ったって
私はびしょ濡れたことないんです
その方が面白い 面白くて明るいんです
傘が弾いたら私たちに文句を言うなよと言ったら
それが明るいでしょ あ
どうか先生 この傘を持ってお体を大事にと言って
それでその女性がどうやって家に帰るんですかね
またあれ 女性が使うか
傘では私がさせちゃうとね
まあそういういろいろありましてね
だから私たちはこのアプローチを変えれば
それだけ人生は楽しいんです
仏教では邪見 ミッチャーディッティ
正見 サマーディッティという 2つの概念があります
俗世間の見方は邪見で決まっている
俗世間は邪見です 苦労して勉強しないと心は正見に変わりません
あの世間はみんな邪見なんです
この邪見正見というのは宗教的な意味じゃないんです
これは真理なんです サイエンスなんです
人間が猿から進化ししまったというような感じなんです
ですから この生命が邪見で生き続けているならば
これ邪見正見にするということはかなり勉強しないとできないんですね
人々は幸福になって楽しく生活するために必死で頑張っています
そこでどんな生命も幸福になりたい
楽しく生きていきたい
そのために頑張るわ 頑張るわ
頑張るわ 人々は頑張っちゃうとどうなるんですかね
世間は日々変わります
100年待つ必要はないんですよ
たった二 三年で世界は変わるんです
すぐすぐ日々変わります
なんで世界が変わる？人間なんです
人間が頑張っているんです
カラスは1万年生き続けたっても
世間は変わりません カラスはそれで満足して
楽しく明るく生活しているんです
ある森に立てばもう千年もクマが住んでいるんだと
森は変わりませんよ クマがいたからといって
なんで世界が変わるんですか？人間がいるからなんです
毎日が変わるんです 毎日
だから人間が世間を変えているでしょ？何のため？幸福になるために
楽しく生きるために それで裏読めない
裏読んでみてください
皆さん いつでも仏教に慣れるためには
この裏も読んでください
裏はカラスは楽しく生活しているのに
犬も楽しく生活しているのに
何も変えなくてもいいやと思っているのに
人間が不幸のどん底ということでしょう
人間にはこのままではダメだ
このままでは苦しいんだ
このままでは不幸だと経験しているから
世界変えて変えて変えて変えていくんです
だから人間が偉い 世界は世界を変えている
文化も作っているとか
偉いと言ったってもね
あれは裏側の考えで 裏読んでみたらアホということになるんです
あんた方は苦しんでいるということになるんです
あんた方は不満で病気だと
あんた方は落ち着いていないんだと
あんた方に安らぎがないんだと
いう話でしょ 裏を見ると
はい 結果は悩み 苦しみ
不幸 苦悩 憂い 悲しみ えーと
まあ不幸 2つ入ってますね
まあいいわ 不幸２倍 増します
だって始めも不幸だから頑張ったでしょ？結果も不幸だったら不幸２倍でしょ
結局は では世界を見てください
我々は幸せになっているんですかね
ただ不幸が増えただけでしょ
で 電話システムが現れて
それからもう携帯時代になってあって
皆様の携帯が今ほとんど端末付きパソコン
ほぼパソコンですね 結構幸せですね
それで ただアホになっただけでしょ
人と喋れない これだってこれだって
なんだこれ こんにちはすら言えなくなっちゃったんです
あれでゲームやってるのを見たら
狙って見たんでちょこちょこと
私もゲームやるよとやることない時やるんですね
それももう悔しくて これはとにかくやってやるぞという
そういう攻撃的にやってるんで
私は別に楽しいなあ これはということじゃないんです
それで勝てないようにプログラム組み立てているとわかったら
この野郎 人を馬鹿にするんじゃないとのゲームやらない
全部買ってしまったら
なんてこたらということ終わっちゃうんですね
まあとにかくまあ意図的にやってるんだから
まあいいそれでも大丈夫だと思ってるんだけど
だから皆様方 時々女性の方々はこうやっていろいろツイッターとかなんとか見ているんですね
あれ何がて 今ご飯食べた？今日はうどん食べた写真載ってね
今日はこのラーメン屋さんに行きましたとかね
こういったラーメン屋さん
看板の前に あんなの気持ち悪くない？あんなものに依存するということは
いかに不幸かということでしょ
そこで生きるための時間
全部費やしてしまっているでしょ
料理作る時間がない 研究
料理作る時間がない スーパーに行って今日は何を出ているんでしょうかとかね
ちょっと見たら楽しいでしょう
そんな暇がないんです
よ とにかくさらに問題が増えるだけ
だから江戸時代と今の時代を比較すると
問題多い精神的な問題というのはどちらですかね
昔は現実的に人を殺されるんですよ
大阪から東京に来たらもう無事帰れるかわからない
その人にそこは悩みもあったんだけど
そういう悩み解決したでしょ
今 大阪から東京にも 1ヶ月間かからないでしょ
2時間40分 45分で
えらい幸せですね 幸せになったんですかね
とにかく原子爆弾あるわ
原発はあるわ 空気が汚れているわ
水が汚れているわ 海も汚れているわ
海から取る魚の体にも毒が入っているわ
それで料理して さらに化学物質を入れて
さらに毒に毒化するわ
かぼちゃを砂糖を入れて煮るわ
それで糖尿病にかかったと泣くわ
それからもう怒れながら運動したり
なんだこれ 昔はもう裸で困りますということで何か着ただけでしょ
今 楽に服さえ着られないでしょ
色は何でしょうか？デザインは何なのかとか
ブランド名前は何なのかとかね
ユニクロの服 あれ今ユニクロも安くないね
ユニクロ嫌になっちゃったんで
一番安くて誰にでも問題なく着られるって作ったんだけど
あの連中 そこはバラバラでね
仕上がっちゃって値段上がったんだけど
品質はそのまま だからまあ気になるのはこれはユニクロだからね
まああれはあれじゃないんだからとかね
これ楽になった 皆様に 100円ショップのアクセサリー作れる？つける
Tシャツはね そこら辺
駅の時々販売やってますね
そちらで買うか 銀座の店で買うか
どちらの方がいい？これは銀座で買いましたよと見たら
同じもの もしかすると新宿駅でも売ってる
こちらね 日暮里駅でも売ってる可能性あります
だって私は半額で 4万円のリュックサック買ってね
これはあまりにも使い勝手良くて
あれを捨てて 1,500円のリュックサック今使っているんです
駅で買ったんです 私は楽しいんです
宣伝までしているんです
このリュックサックは 1,500円だよ
で ブランドのバッジついてるものは半額で 4万か 4万5,000円となったんですね
でもあれは使えないんですね
まあ使いますけど ただみんなに見せびらかすためにね
ほら 見て これはなんだらかんだらのコーチでしたっけ？コーチのリュックサックだよとかね
皆様のリュックサックはこういうブランド入ってないでしょとかね
そんなことを使う もしそんな気持ちだったら
私はどこまで最低不幸な人間ですか？空っぽでしょ？威張りたくなるとなると
だから確かに昔よりは立派なカバンもある
昔は立派な服もある 昔は立派なアクセサリーもある
昔はなかったんだけどね
今はものすごい化粧の種類があるわあるわ
女性っていうのはもともとなんで頭が悪いんですけど
あの化粧の種類勉強しちゃうと頭いっぱいでしょ
他のことを学ぶ暇がないんですもん
ファンデーションにしたっても
いろんなものがあるんだから
昨日それもチェックしたんですよ
あの ざーっと長い列で棚 2つ並べてあったら
あれは全部あの いろんな種類がありまして
あの化粧を落とすミスなんです
あの普通の台所で雑巾洗う石鹸で顔を洗ったら何かなる
何になりませんよ だから
あの 時々女性の方々が来て
シャッシャッとやっても試したりもしてね
そこを勉強して 自分の顔に肌に合うものを選ぶと
この人にはもう料理にどれぐらい塩を入れればいいか
どんな時間でお醤油かけるか分からなくなっちゃうでしょうね
だから毒つけて売ってる冷凍食品持ってきてチンするんです
それであなた方は幸せよとまた思ってるんです
ただ鈍感だけでしょ 鈍感
正しいことを言えばただアホでしょ
そんなものにやられているだけでしょ
踊らしてるでしょ？カモにされてるでしょ
それ喜んでカモになったでしょ
だからバカじゃない？騙されたならば言い訳があるんです
これ喜んで進んでカモになっているんです
それで幸せ？それで悩み苦しみが生まれる
うん 寝たっけ はい これから英語になります
英語にしてませんね 本当は英語だったら至って簡単にこういう風に喋られますけどね
あの日本語 言葉がいろいろないんですよ
面白い大胆なことを喋るためにはね
言葉はあるんだけど フレーズがないんですね
キングミダースと演じるたちって知ってますね
これ 日本語訳する必要ないでしょ
ミダスという王様とたちの
世間の見方が間違っているのです
しかし 見方を変える 訂正する
直す気持ちはありません
世界はもう何千年も頑張ってるんだけど
人類の安らぎがないんです
だったらあなた方の考えを変えなさいでしょ
同じことをやるなよでしょ
だから お父さんお母さんが自分の人生は最悪で
子供の時からもひどい目に遭って
苦労して競争して戦って頑張ったのに
ろくでもない人生に大人になっているんですね
何の役にも立たない それで子供が生まれる
子供にはそんなことはさせたくないと思って
子供には幸せにしてあげたいでしょ
それで何をおっしゃる？自分がやったことを同じことをやってくださいと言うでしょ
アホじゃないんですか？お父さんお母さんがやった生き方
生き方で結果はこの様
だったら言うべきなのね
真似するなよと お父さんとお母さんにも
あんた知ってるでしょ？我々の人生は
それは言わない だからこの世の中の問題は
このずっと科学が発展して
もう二 三百の間で 宇宙にも宇宙船まで送ったりして
一回月に行って戻ってきてね
威張るんですね 月に行って戻ったからといって何かなった？そっちから砂とか石一個持ってきたんだからといって
ただの無駄でしょ あれは
でもさらに研究する さらに研究する
日本も宇宙ステーションのラボ一つ持ってるでしょ
アメリカはもうお金払えませんと逃げましたけどね
それでロシアやら日本やらお金出して出して
そちらに物質を運んだりする
何か大事な研究でもした？人類に幸福になること何か見つけた？何もないでしょ
ただ金無駄になっているだけ
それで何かんげ なおさら研究しなくちゃいけない
スペースラボをもっと
まあスペースラボっていうのはスペースステーションね
これはもっと拡大しなくちゃいけない
それ突然落ちたらどうする？その上
正見について語る人を非難します
例えば 今私はあえて大胆に喋っています
これ一つの方便なんです
なぜなら 皆さんの心の中で
そこまで人を馬鹿にするんじゃないよという気持ちが生まれているはずなんです
あんたわからないでしょ？現代科学的な発展とかね
どこかでネットで誰か書いてあった
私は科学は勉強していないんだぞと
だから何ですか？とお前苦しみのどん底に陥っていて
科学を勉強していて 私はすごい最高幸せだから
怖いもの何もないんだから
だって頭にカビる撃ちたって私はへっちゃらだから
くし抜きで無名で あだ名でハンドルネームで悪口書く
それに私はビビると思う
だからゴートミーのサリーちゃんが自分の奥をすごく自慢しているんです
それで私は落ち込む  笑い
それを知っていると 私はあえてサーリちゃんのことを馬鹿にするんです
だから私は今日はすごい大胆に喋っているのは
皆様の心の中 これって経験してほしいんで
私は言っていることは
そこまでクタクタ悪口言わなくてもいいんじゃないんですかねとかね
科学の騒ぎになっているでしょうとかね
携帯も役に立っているでしょうとかね
そういう反論が起きたりする
反応が起きなかったら皆さんは死んでいるでしょうね
おそらく 私の今までのされたことにね
拒絶反応が起きてないんだったら
おそらく死んでいる さっさと起き上げてもらってください
そこで正見について語ると
人々は本当は批判するんじゃなくて理解できないんです
たとえ私が一つ大胆な例でわかります
だから今日雨が降って出て
外を出ると 私の頭の上に雷が落ちたって
私はよかったね それって思っちゃうと
え？あんた頭おかしくない？と思っちゃうでしょ
冗談言ってるでしょとかね
本当はそうじゃないでしょとかね
と思っちゃうんですね
ということは 私のあの言葉の意味は理解していないんです
私はそのまま言っただけです
だって死は避けられないでしょ
じゃあ病院でベッドで寝たきりになって 2
年間苦しんでやっと死ぬこと幸せ？頭のドカンと雷が落ちちゃって
同時に火葬までしてくれることがなんで幸せじゃないんですかね
だから意味は文字通りなんです
しかし 皆さんの心の中では
そんな残酷なことを言わないでくださいとかね
だって私は今 73 で残りってわかってるで何やるのかと
新しい大胆なことしませんでしょ？もう世の中にも興味もないし
若い時はあれ知りたい
これ知りたい あれやりたいあったんだけどね
今はこの歳には関係ないってことになっているし
だから一番幸せな雷が落ちることはないです
はい とにかく正見について語ると
ちょっと理解できなくなりますね
はい それでは物語に行きましょう
このエジプトマイナーという地方に
この国の名前はプリギア
プリギアンなんだよ フィジア
という国の国王ミダスは
とても裕福な裕福な王でしたが
心が満たせなかったので
触れるものは何でも金に変わる希望があったんです
ものすごく欲張りで 金がもっと豊か
もっと欲しい もっと欲しいと
国民の面倒は見ない 自分だけ財産を握りしめる
すごい狂暴で そこでエピソードはギリシャ物語ですよ
ギリシャ神話 日本語であると思いますけどね
読んでみてください で
ディオニュソスというね
ディオニュソスって この酒とふざける
遊ぶ リベール リベールといいます
神なんですね 酒飲んで踊ってふざけて
その人 神の家来の一人
神が海で旅をすると こいつはもうあまりにも酔っ払ってどうにもなくなっちゃって
遅くなったんです 遅くなって
ディオニュソスがもう先に行っちゃうんです
この人はどうしようもなく
このミダスの国の王の公園で寝たんですね
おそらく酔っ払ってそのまま木の下で寝たでしょうね
そこでこのミダス王が
あ これは神であるとわかってね
すごく丁寧にお世話してあげたんです
そこでディオニュソスが
あ こいつは私の家来のね
よく面倒見てくれたんだよ
いい人やと あんた何か希望があったら言ってください
かなってあげるぞと それで彼が触った触ったものは
こいつはそれを希望していたんだから
本当は私が触ったものは全部金になれば金になれば金ではなくてありがたい
はい 分かった そのやってあげますと
そこでこのミダス王もしかしこれはね
ディオニュソス的な酔っ払っている愛酒の神でしょ
毎日酒飲んでワインの神ですね
で 本当にこいつは言ってることは正しいかどうかね
で 何かなんか触ったらやっぱりすぐ金に変わるんですね
面白くなっちゃって あれ触ってみて
これ触ってみて 全部金になっちゃったんです
朝 自分の食卓の上にバラの花があって
ああ 綺麗な花だ これは代わりはどうかなと取ったら終わり
金になっちゃったんです
ひどい目になっちゃったんです
ご飯食べようと触って触ったら終わり
金 そこで娘さんが来たんですね
おはようございますと言ったら
父さんに すっごいもうお気に入りの娘さんでね
いたらもう抱っこして
おはようと そのままの女が
娘さんが気になっちゃって
悲しくなっちゃって その 1 日でね
で これどうなるかと ご飯食べたければ
こいつはすごい重障がい者としてこうやっていなくちゃあかんですね
それで口に誰かご飯入れてあげないと
やれやれ 希望が叶って
まあストーリーまだ続きありますね
この人は後でちゃんとその問題から神の恵まれたんだけど
この恵みを返しちゃったんです
恵みを返して人格も変えたんです
それから国民の面倒を見る普通の王に戻ったんです
で この石山にはどこかの川に行って手を洗ってくださいと
ディノスが行ったんですね
行ったら自分の手からサーッと金が流れていったんだと
だからその地方でそれから掘ったら金が出るようになりましたって
またいろいろお話がありますけど
まあ全てギリシア物語ですから
全て嘘ですね 真面目に信じたら困ります
でも面白い物語なんですね
その物語で何か言ってるんですかね
人間の希望通りで言ったら最悪ということなんです
ミダスが幸福にならなかったんです
幸福になるために触るものは金になって欲しかったんですね
そうなったらどうですか？というと
どん底不幸になっちゃったんです
はい それで読める 人間の思考見方に問題があるんです
今も現状 が ミダスと同じ希望で生きてるでしょ
まあ触るもの金になれと思ってないんだけどね
多かれ少なかれ人類はミダスのもけしんでしょ
だからミダス王様が自分の希望欲望を全部川に流しちゃったんだから
それでやっと楽しき切られたんです
金はいらない 財産いらない
みんな笑っちゃえばいいと
いて 国民に面倒見てあげたんです
国民は豊かで ご飯食べて歌って踊っているのはよかったねと
その楽しみは楽しかった
だからミダスの皆様方もね
ミダスのひどい目に遭ったことを理解して
この人生やめれば この生き方をね
希望が叶ったならば それこそ不幸でしょ
では皆様の世間論 希望が叶うことはありがたいでしょ
あなたの希望が叶えられますようにと
それから日本のお寺に行ったら
願望上 なんとかと成就
ってお札取れるんですね
あの人たちは不幸になるんです
地獄に落ちようと 希望叶ったら地獄に落ちるんですよ
結局はメタフォリカルでも地獄なんです
ミダス王様は直ちに地獄になっちゃったんです
もう手で何も触れなくなっちゃったんです
だってソファに座ろうかなと触ったらどうなる？ソファは金になりますから
もう硬いでしょ だから仏教では希望は叶わない方がいい
では 一人が希望叶ったら楽しくなる
もう一人が希望叶わなかったら楽しくなる
どちらの楽しみが多い？じゃあ数学的に数字的に
皆様の希望はどれぐらい叶ってますか？例えば希望が 100個ある
100個のものを希望すると
実現できるのはどれぐらい？ 100個じゃないでしょ
結局は数えられないぐらい希望がある
その中で一部叶いますよ
一部は叶いますよ だからわずかでしょ
例えば 100万の希望があって
2つ叶いましたと楽しく喜んでいる
もう一人が 100万の希望があって
一つ除いてすべて失望になったと喜んでいる
何回この人喜びる？じゃあ私は数学下手だから10にします 10
の希望があって 二人の一個一個叶います
一人が一個叶ったぞと舞い上がっている
もう一人は 9つも9つ出たっけ
9つもダメになったと喜んで
この人は 9回楽しいでしょ
あの人は一回だけでしょ
だから希望叶わないことで幸せと思ってください
これはすごい心理なんです
では シミュレーションしてください
皆様の希望が叶ったらどうなる？知らないね
じゃあ質問します 正直に答えてください
死にたい 死にたいと希望してないでしょ？死にたくないという希望でしょ
では希望叶ってあげる
あげたら誰も知らないでしょ
はい イメージしてください
どうなるのか 何やっても知らない
線路を渡ろうと思ったら足がこけちゃって
ペタンと倒れる 電車が自分の体の上でキーっと行っちゃう
でも死なない 幸せでしょ
足は 足は潰れてごっちゃごちゃになる
でも死なない それでまあ 1日 2日じゃなくて断食する
1週間  1ヶ月も 3ヶ月と死なない
幸せでしょ だから死にたくないっていうのは希望でしょ
病気になりたくはないって希望でしょ
年取りたくないって希望でしょ
金持ちになりたいって希望でしょ？あいつには負けたくないって見る見る人に負けたくないでしょ
人間の希望っていうのはあんまりにも恐ろしいものなんです
幸い希望が叶わないんですよ
だから希望がない人ほど幸せな人間がいないんです
どうせ叶うことはないんだから
希望をゼロにする それは阿羅漢になった人の心なんです
そうすると私のたとえわかりますよ
頭の上に雷が落ちたというね
希望がゼロになると極限の幸福になるんです
希望の数 あれ数に合わせて不幸なんです
だって希望っていうのは今満たしてない
物足らない 今は不幸 だけど子供がいい大学に入りたくなる
希望をする 一流の大学に入りたいと
それで明るくはないんですよ
何か自分の中で一流大学に入れなかったらカッコ悪いじゃんとかね
立場がないんだとか こいつらには勝てないんだとかね
自分の仲間に 学校の 苦しんでるんですよ
会社でどうにかして係長になりたいと思っている人が幸せ？思ったその日で係長にならないでしょ
だから係長になるまで毎日不幸を感じているんです
では 何か運命が不運に恵まれて係長になったとしましょう
幸せ？ 1日だけ あんた係長に任命しましたよという紙 1枚もらう時はすごい興奮します
それで奥さんに係長になったよとかね
奥さん何を今から今とは違いますよと
いろいろ会社の人々も家に来るんだからね
いろいろ接待したりする
奥さんには最悪なんですね
それから服装を変えなくちゃいけないわ
行儀作法を変えなくちゃいけないわ
部下の面倒を見なくちゃいけないわ
社員でいた方がよかったのではないかと思う羽目になるんです
こんなに責任持って もし調子が悪くなったら自分のせいになるんです
うん だから人間が希望があるとは
人間が不幸であるという話なんです
そこで必死で希望を叶うために頑張る
本を読む セミナーをやる
いろいろな まあなんとかという系統のね
セミナーをやる 私個人的にはあんな気持ち悪いことよね
まあすぐ金持ちになる方法ね
1ヶ月  3ヶ月間で億万長者になるとか
電子商取引コマーシャルありますよ
いろいろ本のコマーシャル
さんまっていう会社でしょうかね
で 最低の本出して一番金儲かってるから出版じゃない
だって人間がバカだからね
簡単に金儲かる そうなったんですかね
そういう本読んで まず
そういうわけで 人間の見解じゃなくて見方に問題があるんです
いまだに希望があって
楽しいと思っているんです
希望があることはとてもポジティブなアプローチだと
希望があったらこの人は苦しんでいるでしょうに
どこにポジティブですかね
これは無意識的に自分がダメだと認めているでしょう
ただ 俺が金持ちになりたいとは裏読んだら
俺は貧乏ですという意味でしょ？なんで裏読まないんですかね
これが皆様の問題なんです
言葉の表面だけ読むんです
いつでも私から今いろいろ裏の読み方を教えてるんだから
裏も読んでください 金持ちになりたいなと思ったら
あんたは貧乏でしょ？もっと美しくなりたいなと
ちょっともっとと入れるんですね
自分をごまかすために
自分を騙すために そこまで自分が自分の心を騙している
もっと痩せたいと 今痩せているんだったら
もっとなんですかね はい
もっとあってもあんた太りすぎでしょ
自分でそれを認めているんです
なんでこれに気づかないんですかね
本当は人生がこの裏のあれで生きているんです
口先じゃないんです 建前と本音があるんですからね
本音で生きているんです
金持ちになりたいのにったら
本音は俺は貧乏ですと
貧乏で生きているんです
美しくなりたいなと言ったら
何て言うか 反対は ブサイク
ブサイク 不細工で生きているんです
これって明るい生き方ですかね
だって本音で生きているんだから
建前っていうのは ちょっと社会に見せる皮だけでしょ
だから嘘を休み休み言ってほしいんです
これ 人類に言います あまりにも嘘でもアンドロなんですね
ブラックホールなんですね
この暗闇が 光の気配すらがないという
あの本物のブラックホールは明るいんですけど
我々は文学的に妄想するブラックホールは暗いんです
本物のブラックホールは暗くないんです
ただ そちらの光が外に行かないんです
あまりにも重いんだ しかし
明るいブラックホールの写真は撮れません
写真撮るためには光を出さなくちゃかん出してないんです
光が現れても こうやって曲がってまた元に戻るんです
そこで光が上がって曲がる前に
そちらにカメラを持って行っちゃうと
カメラがすべて素粒子に分解されちゃって
ブラックホールに入っちゃいます
そういう存在です はい
天文学はそこで終わりにして
次に行きましょう はい
次 なんで私たちは暗いんですかと
次のテーマは私と私のものと生き方
これみんなにあるでしょ？私がいる
私のものがある その気持ちある限り
あなた方は極端に暗いんです
全く自由がないんです
私は大事 私は私中心にして価値判断したり
考えたり 生きたりします
みんなそうでしょ 私中心に考えているんです
私中心に価値判断しているんです
生きる時はいつでも私が主語で私が生きているんです
何やっても私 私 私 私という風になっているんです
私は私のために生きています
私は私のものがたくさんあります
私のものがあればあるほど私は幸福です
成功者です だから世間は言ってる
成功っていうのは私のものが増えることなんですね
例えば金メダル取ったら成功しましたと
私のもの増えただけです
私はメダリストだという
私はメダルを持っている
できることなら世界制覇したいんですね
目指すと何も変わりはないんです
知識 学問 技術 権力などの私のものです
だからそれは理解してください
この私のものというのは
このカバンが私のもの
この靴が私のもの これでしょ
知識も私のもの 技術も私のもの
いろいろ専門学校に入って技術を学ぶでしょ
この私のものにするんですね
能力を はい それで自家製の暗黒
結果は私がいるならば
たと競争しなくていけないでしょ
競争する羽目になるんです
負けてはならないでしょ
自我を守るために暇がなく
頑張らなくてはならないでしょ
はい 暗くならなかった？これこれほどネガティブシックある？これから戦う私がいるのなら
みんなと戦わなくちゃいけない
自分を守らなくちゃいけないでしょ
その人は笑えませんよ
だってどんな人間も暇がなく頑張ってるんです
私を守るために ちょっとスライドで書いてないんだけど
延長線で喋ります 例えば
あなたって本当に アホですねと言われたら気持ち悪くなるでしょ？なんで私がいるからなんです
あんた何やっても失敗ばっかしでね
役に立たない人間だと言われたら
最悪ね なぜ私がいるからなんです
だから人が喋っただけで私が不幸になる
人がふざけただけで私が不幸になる
例えばある子供が遊んでいるゲームやっていて
人の指を指して あなたのバカ
あなたのバカ あなたのバカ
あなたのバカと言ってて遊んでいるんです
そこで子供は回ってまた自分の方に来ると
自分がビビってるんです
ちっちゃな子供にあなたのバカですと言われると
年上の人がかなり傷つくんです
たったあの子供のふざけた言葉だけでしょ
あんなもんで心が傷つくんだから
これで明るく生きられる
犯人は誰？私 私っていうあの錯覚でしょ
他人の評価 批判などが気になってしまいますね
では 他人の批判 気になってない人がいる
だから怯えて どぶねずみみたいに周りを見たら
あちら見てあちら見て
瞑想を教える時でもそうなんですね
周り何かやっているの見つめ
真似するんです 瞑想にならないんです
ある一回 私はゆっくり手を上げることを教えたんですね
はい スタートやってくださいと言ったら
こいつは私を見ているんですね
私はやってないんですね
これはもうプログラムです
私は猿を育てているわ
猿軍団なんとかやってないですからね
私は猿は要りません だから私は手を上げたら猿がやるんですよ
それしかできんだからね
猿に それで私はやってないんだから
この何人かいたんで いろいろそういう知識ぶってそういう風にいるんです
やらない このバカがね 3
分もそういう風にいたんです
何もしないで だからそいつは精神的に安楽にならなかった
安穏にならなかった 私のせいですかね
人間失格でしょ 結局は
そこで時々一緒に体触れるぐらいのそばに座っている人がやると
その人のやり方を真似るんですね
それで瞑想にならないでしょ
そこでゆっくり体の手の感覚を感じて
思考を止めて そちらに安らぎがあるんだよと発見したいところ
この人の真似すればいいんですね
そうするんです なるほどな
何も心に入ってないでしょ
だからこれは瞑想ではありません
瞑想会やる度に 私はそういうひどい目に遭わなくちゃいけないんですね
それで私はなんで真面目にやってほしいと思うんですか？と思ったことが自分の希望で
それで苦しんでいるんだと
人は真面目に修行して幸福に達してほしいと思ったことに問題があるんだと
ですから言葉変えたんです
どうぞ勝手に地獄に落ちてください
俺には関係ないんだと
それは私のウダーナなんです
安らぎの言葉 どうぞどうぞ
勝手に地獄に行ってください
関係ないんだからと はい
次 財産を比較する 体の形を比較する
衣装を比較する 住所 住むところ
住み処を比較する 互いに病気さえ比較しますね
これで これって明るい人生ですかね
この世俗世間の生き方って何なのかね
みんなもうみんなやること真似てるでしょ
結局は だって昔も同じことやっていたでしょ
比較するは比較するは
財産を比較する はい 私には 100坪がある
それで田中にはね  400坪でしょ
あいつにはね と言ったら
自分が暗くなってるでしょ
あるいは私のは 100坪ですけど
田中にはたった 100坪でしょう
なんだあれはと思っちゃうと
自分が苦しんでいるでしょ
空っぽでしょ 地球の面積で自慢するんだから
バカバカらしくて ここから面積を計算して数字で自慢する
400で 100 なんだこれ
比較しては悩む 落ち込む
暗くなる 傲慢になる 凶暴になる
24時間のセキュリティの中で怯えつつやっと生きてるんです
で 比較するものが増えると
もう厳しくセキュリティシステムを作って
窓を開けたら警報鳴るわ
ドア開けたら警報鳴るわ
ドアを開けて 40 秒以内で暗証番号を押さなくちゃいけないわ
うかつに庭で散歩しようかなと思ったらギャーっと警報鳴るわ
これで幸せやと思っているんですね
それが面白いんですよ
あの精神病院で 例えば
ある人が自分が医者だと思っている
精神的な病気なんですね
本人が真面目に医者やと思っているんですね
そこで本当の医者が来るんですね
病棟に 医者が来てどうですけど
そしたらこの病気な人が友達に
あいつは病気でしょ？医者やと思っているんだからね
俺が医者なのに 本人病気なんですね
だから本物の医者に お前頭イカれてるんだと
いうような世界でしょ
生きているの 毎日 だからそれは私
私のという思考パターンから生まれる苦しみなんです
はい それで自家自分で作った暗黒でしょ
これ 英語ではセルフインプリゾンメント
日本訳はわからなかったんですね
刑務所にある 自分で刑務所を作って
自分がそこで囚人になる
自分もで鍵を作って鍵をかけて
出禁できないように閉めてから鍵を
鍵を捨てる 捨てて 誇らしげに生きている
刑務所の中で はい これわかりやすくします
私よりは私のもの ペットとして犬か猫を飼う
してみてください あなたの自由がその時点でなくなりますね
はい ペットショップに行って箱を買って
あるいは箱を借りることもできますからね
はい お金払ってペットもらうでしょ？あの瞬間からどうなる？自由がなくなるんです
私のものでしょ 私のものは自分の自由を奪いますよ
自分を暗くしますよ 時間経つとあなたはペットの奴隷になって
人間としてのプライドすらなくなります
それで猫か犬を飼うでしょ
買って毎日面倒を見る
友達がどこへ休みだからどこか行きましょうって言っても行けない
ペットがいるんだから
はい 大変面倒くさい ペットホテルに預からなくちゃいけないんですね
預かりたくない あそこでは可愛い可愛い犬どうして預かる？あの受ける受付はいいです
あー可愛いですね 大事に大事に面倒見てあげますから
安心して帰ってくださいって言うんです
出て行ったらドカンと振り合わせんだ
檻に ちっちゃな檻作ったって
それの中入れて餌を餌と水をあげて鍵かける
終わり それ知ってるんだったら
ペット 何て言ったっけ？ホテルにも預かりたくないでしょ？自分が奴隷になってるんじゃない？そこでペットが病気になるでしょ
悲しくない？それでペットが先に死ぬでしょ
悲しくない ある ある 日本のちょっと自分たちが偉いと思ってる家柄の人なんですけど
私はそう思ってなかったんだけどね
兄弟でものすごく憎しみ合うんですね
喋ったら罵り合ったりして
だから私に間に入って
みんなに理性教えてくださいと頼まれて行ったんです
だから誰に理性教えてもわからなくなっちゃうんですね
みんな頭イカれてるんです
ほったらかして罵り合っちゃって
まあくだらない財産のためなんです
どちらにも何の役にも立たない財産があったんだけど
しかし この古い家で住んでる人には
他の東京に住んでる人は家をあげたくないんです
じゃああなたこちらに住む？えー
私は東京にマンションがありますからと
しかし この家やこの人にあげたくないんだと
理由を聞いたら いい このお嫁さんがね
元宝塚の女優でね だからすごい
なんて言いますかね ねぶり手振りとかね
あれで美しくてかっこつけてみんな騙してるんだと
私に言うんだ あんたね
すごい美人だからね 挨拶つけた歩く姿
それ見てね 騙されるなよと
私にどこまで頭イカれてるのかと
私が最初からこいつらはもう脳みそがない
もうロボットやと思ってるのにね
だからそんなもんなんですね
私のものはいらないのに
この人にあげたくない
はい そこは一つのエピソードで
その時 東京に住んでるその方が猫を飼っていたんですね
猫が老衰で死んじゃったんです
1週間 この方泣いた 泣いてもうご飯も食べないで落ち込んでいるんです
兄弟を殺したがってる人なんですね
そこで私に連絡があってね
これ大変ですよと なんとかして猫のお葬式やって天国に行かせてあげてくださいと
そうすると自分にはちょっと安心できますよと
はい わかりましたと行って
私はOKをあげて あの死んだ猫を天国に行かせてあげて
どこまでアホですかね
天国に行ったと思う？あの猫が
だからアホに付き合うと私までくだらないドラマやらなくちゃいけない
私はちゃんとすごく真剣に
あの 何と言いますか お経を上げて法事をやって
えらい真剣に テーラワーダやりませんよ
犬猫のお葬式なんかは
そんな方法すらないんです
どうせパーリ語の経典わからないんだから
なんとか何とか言ってやれちゃって
それで確かに何々ちゃんがね
まあ天国で喜んでいるでしょう
あんたもそこで気分明るく普通の生活に戻ってくださいって戻ります
普通の生活に 生活の一応
まああえて言います キリスト教なんです
そういう キリスト教って神父さんに頼んだ方がいいでしょ
どこまで頭いかれるんですかね
これ まるまる仏教の暴走でしょ
だからそういうことは実例もあるんだけどね
それはすごい その方は亡くなったんだから
今何の躊躇もなく言えますだけどね
今まで誰もいなかったんだけど
で 人間としてね 配慮すらなくなっちゃって
犬猫の奴隷になる だから兄弟が死んだ方が待ちやと思ってる人は
猫が死んじゃってしょうがねえしょうが泣くということは
これで理性？だから私のものっていうのはいかに危険かでしょうに
裏読んでみたら はい それが自由で幸福な生き方だと思うならば
私のものをたくさん獲得してください
例えば ペット1匹飼って幸せになるでしょ
だったら10匹ぐらい飼っちゃうと
たくさん 私みたいな 1,500円のカバンも私のものですけど
1,500円だから 今はだいたい4,000円ぐらいの価値の使ってるんだからね
結構使ってるんだから
あれが破れたからといって私は損しませんね
皆様方はできるなら ブランドのカバンっていうのは
一番安いものは 20 万ですね
で 役に立つような使えるようなものだったら 30
万  40 万ぐらいになるんです
そうやって私のものをどんどんどんどんいっぱい入れてください
どうなるのかと 完璧アホになるんです
完璧に暗くなるんです
自分が高価なカバンを持っているとしましょう
高価な靴を持っているとしましょう
そこで自分の兄弟の家族が入ってくる
そちらにえらいじゃんちゃの2
3歳の子供が二人ぐらいいるとしましょう
こいつらおばあちゃんの家であっち走ってこっち走ってね
そこで靴下駄箱を開けたらピカピカのね
靴見つかるんです 子供は見つかって
それでパンパンやったり
子供喧嘩したりしちゃうとどうなる？それで子供二人キャッチボールやっちゃうと
想像してください カバンそばにあったところで
子供がもうアイスクリームソフトクリーム食べたりして
あるいは水を飲んだりしてこぼしちゃった
カバンの上にどうなる？ 50万円の
あるいは100万円のカバンですけど
だから子供にその時は人権を侵害して当たるでしょう
自分の兄弟に悪口を言うでしょう
しつけが間違っているんだとか
間違ってるのは誰ですかね
このくだらない土の奴隷になった人じゃない
子供は自然そのものですけど
ピカピカ光ってるんだったら
踏んだり蹴ったりするのは当たり前なんです
子供にとっては 兄弟をぶん殴りたかったら
靴を取って この靴はもう40万だったけど
子供には関係ないんです
言ってぶん殴るんです
これ殴ったら相手が避けちゃうんだから
この靴が  400万円で買った何かクリスタル
坪に当たって坪がボカンと割れちゃうと
はい 苦しいのは子供ですか？持ち主ですかね
最低姉さまは必要だから車買ったりするでしょ
普通の軽自動車 日本車で日本製のもの買う
もう一人がすごい金があるんだから
外車でなんとか あまり外車で名前を思い出せませんだけど
今思い出したのはポルシェなんですけど
ポルシェの高級車買う
誰が苦しむ？   100万円で軽自動車買った人が苦しむ
どこか何かにちょっと触れたって
ペンキがちょこっとあったら苦しむ
それでまあしょうがないということで終わっちゃうでしょ
バンバン荷物入れるでしょ
子供はそちらに乗っちゃって
ハチャメチャ蹴ったり踏んだりしてね
ある車を見たんで 窓ガラスにも子供の足跡が
こいつら座ってもう蹴ってるんですね
だからそこはある程度で安い車だから楽しいんですね
子供の自由に遊べるんだから
これポルシェだったらどうなる？ポルシェよりも高いいろいろ車ありますけどね
はい そういうことで 私のものっていうのは
自分で地獄を作ることになります
私のものを増やすために
人間であることを諦めて
自分が自分で築いた刑務所で終身刑を受けてください
これ終身刑です はい これでテキスト以外喋れます
この世の中で私もいないということは仏教の智慧ですからね
それは置いておきましょう
これは瞑想で発見する
うん あ これ途中でやめる羽目になります
時間行ってしまったんです
で 私のものっていうのは一つもないんです
これは土です 地球の体も地球から借りた土です
これは返さなくちゃいけない
お金を払ったからって
自分のお金じゃない カバン買ったから自分のカバンじゃない
地球のものです だから私のものっていうのは一つも成り立たない
この土地は 100坪ですけど
私のものやと 本当？私のものじゃないでしょ
だからまあ はい 次に行きます
それから飛ばします 老いたくない
これ希望でしょ 若さ保つために必死ですね
若さが不幸の楽しみの頂点でしょうかね
なんで老いたくないと思うんですかね
若い時は最高に幸福にいたんですかね
若い時 どれぐらい問題あったんですかね
若い人はどれぐらい悩んでたんですかね
若い人には自分の好みがあっても希望があっても
なかなか親がものすごい厳しくてやらせてくれなかったでしょう
だから若い時は最悪でしたのに
年取ってくるとやっぱり年取りたくはないと思うんですね
よくわからない この考えは
若い人々に悩み苦しみがないんでしょうか
若さを保ちたいという気持ちは非科学的で狂った考えです
だって命っていうのは細胞が衰えることなんです
細胞は変化するんです
これ 細胞が変化して欲しくないと思うことでしょ
で 考えても 自分の細胞が石灰化しましたと
もう変化しません 骨と同じく
若さを保たければ みんな体を石灰化にしてください
命もないです それだったら
なんでそんな非科学的なことを考えるんですかね
若さを保つために四苦八苦で悩む人は
自然の流れで老いたらさらに苦しみに陥るんです
だから若さを保ちたいという人
思ったら それから地獄の門が開いているんです
それで苦しむんです それで現実に年取るでしょ
さらに苦しくなるんです
まず非科学的 ありえない
だったら 老いたことを楽しんでください
毎日老いることを楽しんでみてください
だって若い時やらなくてはいけないこといっぱいやったでしょ
これはもうできなくなったんだからよかったねとかね
例えば女の子が結婚したい
結婚したいと思って思って
あまりにも頭おかしいんだから相手が見つからなくて
それで 40歳  40  50歳
45歳とかなる もう立候補できなくなっちゃったんですね
結婚同士で年取ったでしょ
楽しめば あ 結婚相手探すっていうことはもう関係ない
楽ちんだ どんな男見たって友達関係でお前なんだいっていう感じで生活するんだと
楽やと これはと 結婚する狙いがあると
ちょっと丁寧にね 振り回さないと
結婚は諦めたところで
すごく簡単に使えるんです
それから私は最高に健康に生きたい
I want to maintain best health ですね
これはもう健康でいたいという
病気に陥りたくない と皆は希望します
病気になったら不幸 苦しみを
感じます 健康を保つために努力は苦しいんです
失敗して病気にかかったら悔しくなります
体が病気という壊れて壊れる現象で構成されています
この細胞っていうのは壊れるという法則で成り立っているんです
壊れると新たなものを作る
壊れると新たなもの それは病気なんです
名前を入れるとなれば
だから病気があるとは生きていることなんです
なのに病気は嫌がっちゃうんですね
あまりにも変です 病気になることは苦しいんですよ
別に これ不思議に思う必要はないんです
そうですね それ終わり
風邪を引いたらもう体が体だるくなる
そうですね 風邪を引いてるんだから
今だるい ちょっと動きが鈍い
動きたくなくなっている
じゃあちょっと横になりましょう
ちょっと日焼けがしますから
なんか毛布でもかけ そんな程度でしょうに
なんでそれに悩むんですかね
この事実を知らない限り
認めない限り 幸福になるはずはありません
だから人は病気になるんだと当たり前だと認めない限りは
人間は幸せになりません
健康を期待する生き方が暗い生き方です
また逆説でしょ じゃなくて
これが事実です 健康は期待することはできません
なぜならば 病気が必要です
生きるために 時間ないんだから
そのまま飛ばしていきます
死を避けたい また同じ問題ですね
生命は皆 死を避けたいのです
行うことのすべて 苦労のすべて
希望 願望のすべて 死を避けるためです
生まれた瞬間から死なないために頑張ったんです
苦労苦難して生きていて
死を迎えるとき 極端に怯えて震えて
恐怖感に陥って不幸で死ぬんです
死にたくないと思ったら
その人は生きる 1 秒  1 秒不幸です
死ぬときも極端に不幸に陥って死ぬんです
だから極端な黒い気持ち
暗い気持ちで死ぬと 次も言わなくてもわかる
天国じゃないんです この間がある限り
人は不幸で生きていて
不幸で死んで不幸の境地を思うんです
面白い 死にたくないという気持ちがあったら
地獄 地獄は確定 大丈夫です
頑張ってください 死にたくないために
安心して地獄に行けます
これが暗黒的な生き方ですね
誰だって死ぬんだと思ったらね
いかに幸福かといかに笑えるのかと
人が死んだってびっくりも何ともない
あ そう 死んだの？うん
そうでしょう 誰だって死ぬんだから
それだけです 思考妄想で自分特有の墓穴を掘る
それから思考妄想も人の暗い生き方の原因ですね
預金百万がある人とあると威張っている人が
友人の預金が 500 万だと知った時点で不幸に悲しみに自己嫌悪に陥ります
簡単です あなたの幸せを壊すことはいたって簡単です
私は 4 カラットのダイヤがついてるチェーン持ってるんだと
簡単です 誰か人を探してね
あの 10 カラットのダイヤ持ってる
あんた 10 カラット持って
ちょっと持ってください
これ この人に見せてと
それだけで終わりです
ちょっとあなたのネックレス
この人に見せて 見ただけで自分の幸せが壊れるんです
これ 妄想の結果なんですよ
東大を卒業して自信満々で会社に入ったら
オックスフォード大学卒業者が隣の机に座っているんですね
終わりですね 幸せが たったほんのわずかなことで
これで幸福感が終わります
会社は不公平だ 政治は不安だ
皆私のことを嫌いだ 云々の妄想で不幸に達する人々もいます
だから妄想の不幸っていうのはあまりにも膨大だから
それはもうそれしか教えられません
妄想は不幸を作るんです
科学的でない 論理的でない思考が不幸を作るんです
論理的科学的に考えると楽しくはなるんです
こうだからこうなっちゃって
だからこうなってるとかね
例えば数学の問題なんか解決するときは楽しいんです
はい そこまで邪見の世界ですね
いわゆる俗世間のこと
皆様にも経験ある世界だから
そうして じゃあ正見の世界に戻ったら
そちらに安穏安らぎがぴったしあるんです
そこで その場で安穏安らぎなんです
時間かかりません だから仏教は今幸せになってくださいという話なんです
邪見のアプローチで不幸になっているので
理性を持ってアプローチを変えるんだ
アプローチを変えてみましょう
正見というのは四聖諦を理解することなんです
正四聖諦 正っていうのは世間の考えではない
だからいきなり言っちゃうと
ちょっと納得いかない
ちょっと理解できないということはありますね
サンプルは結構出しました
私は大胆な言葉をいろいろ言ったでしょ
あれは正見で言ったんです
で 皆様方はえっ ちょっとと思ったでしょ
目覚めてありのままに観察してみましょう
生きることが苦しいんです
終わりのない戦いです
希望を期待する通りには進まない
これでしょう 事実は これ認めたらどうですか
認める必要は 信じる必要はない
見てください 自分の人生を
どれほど苦労して生きてきたのかと
それで終わりがないでしょう
今日で苦労終わりない
また家に帰ったら料理作らなくちゃいけないわ
明日なんだらかんだらしなくちゃいけない
お風呂に入らなくちゃいけない
終わりがない 踏ん張ってみても
結局は避けたかった生老病死で終わるんです
踏ん張ったからといって幸福になりません
頑張る人も頑張る人 頑張らない人
みんな生老病死で終わります
現実は苦なのに 悔しくなって諦めず
さらに挑戦する これが我々のちょっと精神的な問題だ
何かやるでしょ？失敗するでしょ？悔しいんです
またやるんです また失敗して
また悔しい またやるんです
それでうまくいった うまくいったっても大したこと
とはない で 悔しい 別なことに挑戦する
例えば何か大根料理作ろうとする
うまく出来上がらなかった
悔しい ちょっと 5分オーバーになった
火にかけて 悔しい またやってみる
そうすると別なこと 何か間違えちゃう
またやってやりたくなる
それで一回 もしかすると希望どおりの大根料理出来上がったかも
食べたら あの 何のこともない
こんなもんやって終わっちゃうんです
また悔しくなる その時は別な料理作ろうとなるんです
現実に満足できない状況状態は渇愛と執着というんです
だから我々には渇愛 執着があるんです
だから僧侶帽子があるのに戦って
逆らって戦うんです 執着が不幸
苦しみの原因です 苦しみ生きることに
苦しみというのは生きること
仏教は生きること生きると言わない
苦しみ一言でね 執着を捨てることが安穏幸福に達する道です
だから苦に執着捨ててくださいよ
当たり前の話でしょうに
生きることは空だと発見してください
発見した時点で執着捨てるんです
執着を捨てる方法とは正八正道ですね
を実践することです 八正道は具体的な生き方なのです
宗教じゃないんです 正見
正思惟 正語 正語 正命 正念
正定 なんだらかんだらですね
日本語で言えないんだ
パーリ語だったら言えますけどね
普通の生き方なんです
正しい見解を持つ 正しい思考をする
正しい言葉を発する 正しい行為をする
正しい職業をする 精神的に集中する
いつでも観察した生き方をする
それだけです それで最後のサммаサマーディというサマーディ静寂サマーディが統一して安穏に達する
修行でも苦行でも神秘でもなく
理性に基づいて生きることです
八正道というのは 八正道とは普通に生きることです
聖師正体を理解する人の明るい生き方に
世間の楽しみはかなわないんです
世間でちょっと音楽を聴いて
どこかでご飯食っちゃって楽しいでしょ
それは楽しいんですよ
どこかにいて 音楽をかけて踊ったりして
カラオケで歌ったりして
当然それ楽しいんです
しかし そんなのはもうかなわないんですよ
四諦を知っている人の安穏と楽しみには
まるっきり比較にならないぐらい安穏
楽しみが生まれるんです
はい それからいろいろ瞑想方法で明るく生きる
ブッダの塾ですからね
お釈迦様は人に幸福になるためにいろんなものを教えたんですね
一つの瞑想フレーズは
サッベーサンカーアニッチャー
一切の現象は無常ですと
だからすべて無常 無常
これは無常 これは無常
これがこれが全部無常だったら
なんで悩む？無常だから別に消えるんです
川が流れることに悩む
誰かが流れなくなったら悩みなくちゃかんでしょ
だから例えば電気が流れている
誰も悩まないでしょ もし電気の流れが止まったらどうなる？これ大変に悩む羽目になりますね
真っ暗になるんだから
で 無常に逆らう生き方が叶わない
希望が必ず失う暗黒的な生き方です
そこで希望あるというのは
無常に逆らうことなんです
逆らえない だから放っておけばいいのです
そういうわけで 精神的な安穏を期待する人は
サッベーサンカーニッチャーっていう瞑想
これ瞑想の言葉なんですね
それは念じておくんです
念じて理解して置いておくんです
次 サッベーサンカーラドッカ
だから仏教はいつでも裏を読んでほしい
だから表で暗い言葉を言うんです
裏はすごい明るいんです
すべてのものごと現象は苦
空しい 無価値である 何にも価値がない
何一つ ダイヤモンド宝石も石です
金はただの金属です カバンはアルミであろうか
もっと安いコーチであろうか
革ですね 動物の 大した価値が大したではなくて
価値がないと思ったら
それはサッベーサンカルドッカ
そうすると楽になるんですね
心の悩み 苦しみが消えるんです
例えば 家が潰れたと悩むでしょ
家に価値が入れたからなんです
土を持って組み立てたものだからね
潰れちゃったら終わり
価値がゼロと思ったら楽なんです
次の瞑想フレーズはジービタンアニエタンマラナンニエタン
死は不安 命は不安 無常
死は確定 確実 生きるっていうことはすごく不安で成り立たない
不確定 死ぬっていうことは確実
それは事実 それは頭に入れておくと
すごく人生が明るくなります
すごい頭のいい人間になります
先生  はい  命があります
生ん？最初のところに命が不安でありますが
死の反対が生ですから
生は恒常するわけです
うん まあ生でもいいんですね
ジービタンというのは
まあパーリ語では語呂を合わせていますから
日本語でちょっと語呂合わせ難しいんですね
ジービタンアニエタンマラナンニエタン
ジービタンというのは生きることなんですね
生きることは不確定 不安であって
死ぬという現象は確実であるというね
まあ適当に直してみてください
とにかく瞑想文章だから
パーリ語で覚えた方が語呂合わせ全部できているんだからね
次の瞑想文章はサッバンパエガンタッバン
これ いろいろ人の性格に合わせている
いろんな瞑想なんです
ただフレーズ変えるだけ
サッバンパエガンタッバン
すべてを捨てていかなくてはならない
事実でしょ 知識も捨てる
会社の社長であることも捨てる
家も捨てて 家族も捨てて死ぬんです
最初からそれを覚えておけば
いろんなもの見えるでしょ
全部捨てていく 捨てていく
捨てていかなくちゃいけない
捨てていかなくちゃ いかなくてはいけない
ガンタバンならない それを念じる
念じると 直ちに精神的にすごい健康な人間になって
すごい明るくなります
はい それ最後にたとえ話をして終了します
人々が巨大なクソの釜を見つかります
ひどい悪臭を放っていたので
解決を考えます これ クソの釜にこれ臭くてどうしましょうかと
ある人がこれをかき回すと七宝に変わるのだという
ある人 あのね クソ臭い臭いとね
この気持ち悪い顔をしないでくださいと
もっとニコッと笑って希望を持ってかき回してください
これは七宝に変わりますよと
皆必死で釜のクソをかき回します
悪臭が増えるだけで七宝にはなりません
それで研究するんです
何か問題あるんだと じゃあ水をかけてみよう
で 生肉をかけてみよう
尿をかけてみよう 人間の尿をかけても七宝にならなかったんですね
では 動物の尿をかけてみよう
牛の尿をかけてみようと研究するんです
あるいは動物の死骸いろいろ入れてかけてみようと
かき回してみます 研究します
まだ七宝になっていないんです
結果はさらにひどい臭くなるんです
それで 自分が今まで研究したレポートを次の世代に教える
次の世代の人々も新たなものを入れて入れてかき回すんです
それでも七宝にならない
それでその研究を持っていって
次の世代に渡す そちらも新しい研究をしながらクソをかき回すんです
で まだ七宝にならないんです
という意味合わせましょう
仏教は色声香味触法はクソに例えています
かき回してるでしょ 人は様々な研究
発明 開発などをして幸福を探しています
結局は色声香味触法を変えるだけなんです
みんな研究したっても
新しい携帯を発明しまったと言ったっても
色声香味触法だけなんです
あの研究の結果 何か入れただけなんです
クソの中に同じクソです
誰にもクソをかき回しても七宝に変わる変わりませんと断言する勇気はありません
でも 遠い昔からやってきたんだからね
価値があると思っているんですね
このクソの釜に だから勇気がない
例えば今 私の説法はそういう説法で
すぐ乗ってみようと勇気が出てこない
そんなこと言ってもね
今までやってきた生き方がね
大事だよと 結局 じゃあクソを回してください
ブッダはクソの釜を捨てなさいと説く
現に身世親で色も色声香味触法に頼るなよと言っているんです
はい 楽に自由に生きられます
クソの釜 そのまま放っておけば
面倒くさくはないんです
離れれば そこに七宝になるだろうと
あのアホな期待を捨てちゃえば
あ 終わりました よかった
はい それでは会場から追い出されるギリギリの時間になってしまいましたので
最後 最後の言葉 最後に皆さんで祈願をして終了したいと思います
ドゥッカパッターチェニン
ドゥンカーバヤンパッターチェニンバヤ
スーカパッターチェニン
スーカーホントサンデーティパーニの
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しむなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しむなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
はい どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました
カンティパラマンタポティティンカーニッバーナンパラマンワダンティブッダ
あ